ich mein' während andere länder zum
beispiel energiepreise deckeln in
frankreich steigt steigt der strompreis
in diesem jahr um vier prozent im ganzen
jahr der sprit diesel und benzin sind um
40 cent pro liter billiger als hier und
während also hier alles weiter nach oben
geht hat unser toller
wirtschaftsminister die idee das mache
ich noch mal ein bisschen was oben drauf
machte gas umlage und lässt auch noch
die energie lobbyisten diese gasanlage
also das gesetz dafür schreiben und
wundert sich dann dass es genauso
aussieht wie es aussieht wenn hobbyisten
von unternehmen sich ein gesetz basteln
nämlich ein selbstbedienungsladen also
insoweit das ist ja eine folge von
ausfällen und ich sag mal wenn nur ein
minister schlecht drauf wäre in dieser
ampel obwohl das ist ja ein schlüssel
das so aber auch das wäre schon schlimm
genug aber es ist ja die ganze regierung
ich meine die haben den ernst der lage
nicht erkannt und das ist ja wieder das
thema auf was hab ich ja so versucht
kleinzureden die insolvenzwelle hat ja
schon begonnen die insolvenzen steigen